six million subscribers six million
people that is just incredible so soon
after five million - recently I was
given the honor of being invited to the
White House now I don't really care what
your view on politics is or how the
government's working that's not why I'm
talking about it but I was there with
many other youtubers and we were brought
in to talk about how we were influential
to the new generation and how we should
strive to inspire you guys and point you
in the right direction and it was a true
honor to be there and be distinguished
because I am a do feat pantsless gamer
from podunk nowhere and somehow I
managed to amass a community that was
recognized on a national scale invited
out even if it was for a short meeting
the fact that it happened was incredible
and we talked and we talked and we
discussed about how youtubers were able
to influence people and how we could
change people and how we could do good
in the world but the same thing kept up
in the entire meeting with this idea
that we had all the power was this idea
that we were in control of what you guys
think and we were there to tell you guys
what to do and it may not have been said
in those exact words but that was the
theme that I picked up while I was
sitting there and it kind of rubbed me
the wrong way not because they were in
the wrong about her because they had bad
intentions but because I've never
believed that I was in charge of you
guys where I had power over you guys
because you guys have made it very clear
or I've tried to make it very clear to
you that I'm only here because of you I
may be the leader in this community but
in all honesty this community would be
nothing
that is people and the major problem
that we solve or we have today is that
people don't feel like they're making an
impact and whatever they do in the
community that they live in or the
community that they choose on the
internet they never feel like their word
is heard and that's the major problem
that's the only reason why people like
me you represent you and it's not what I
want it's not the ideal it's not what I
think should happen it's not the goal
that I think we should strive for
because you guys have so much more power
than you think you guys have the ability
to do so much more than you know even if
you feel lost in the sea of numbers that
doesn't mean that you are insignificant
in any way that doesn't mean that you
don't have a voice that can be heard
that doesn't mean that you can make a
difference and the point that I'm trying
to make from all this is because I never
believed that I was put in this position
to tell you what to do and I never
wanted to you guys can do literally
anything you don't need to be spoon-fed
by someone like me to tell you
which direction you should go and in all
honesty I would rather listen to you
guys and have you guys tell me what to
do then the other way around
and one of the major things that happens
a lot in this community is people ask me
how do I become a youtuber how how do I
do this thing how do I get started how
do I make my dreams come true
any variation that question is always
asking me and I the answer is so simple
and yet it's so hard to tell people
exactly why that's the answer but the
simple truth is if you want to do
anything anything at all no matter how
hard it may seem to do it the only thing
you have to do is start
like a journey of a million miles may
seem like a really daunting and
impossible task
especially when you see like people that
have already started the trip and
already far down the road and re so much
better than you think you'll ever be but
that's just not true you just need to
start because they were once at the same
place you were they started with nothing
or they started with something and it
doesn't matter because they kept going
from where they were you just need to
start him whatever you do and take the
first step because if you can take the
first step then you're going to be able
to know that the journey ahead isn't
that bad or maybe it is bad maybe it's
constant struggle throughout your entire
life but that's not what's important the
important thing is if you want anything
you need to start the idea that I've
been bouncing around while it's trying
to figure out what I was going to say in
this vlogs that you know it's it's a
fundamental principle that we all agree
on it's a pursuit of happiness it's not
the spoon-feeding of happiness it's not
the giving of happiness it is the fact
that if you want something you need to
earn it and that may sound harsh and
that may sound like I'm yelling at you
or telling you that you're not good
enough but that's just not the case
I'm telling you that if you want to do
something you can do it like you guys
can do anything when I say that I
believe in you guys that's not a
falsehood that's not me just blowing
smoke up your ass that's me literally
saying that I know what this community
can do and I know what six million
people can do together and I know that I
have a responsibility to this community
to show you guys that I'm not here for
my own selfish reasons I'm only here
because of you and I am always grateful
for the opportunity that you have given
me and if I can use this position where
I am in front of six million people who
thought that my videos were worthy
enough of watching I don't even care if
you thought that it was just going to be
like silly entertaining videos like this
is important this is always going to be
important this community is going to be
unbelievably important and I've always
taught in almost every vlog that I've
done about this community and how proud
I am of what you have done and that's
never going to change I just want you to
know that after six million subscribers
and after over two thousand videos I'm
still so happy to be able to be here
among you guys you guys are so special
to me and someday you won't need someone
like me to represent you you guys will
someday have your voices heard and every
one every single person will be able to
make their mark on it so anyway that's
pretty much what I wanted to say just
it's hard to put into words how I really
feel sometimes but I always want you to
know
that I believe if you can do anything
and moreover I believe that we can do
anything together so thank you everybody
so much for watching thank you for 6
million subscribers
I can't wait for more I can't wait for
more videos more than just more people
but I can't wait to do more fun things
with this and more great things that
we'll do down the future so thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye